we're talking about this this soap this
this trajectory of hopefully becoming
more and more self-abiding in that and
channeling that
as artistry through us um
where what is the what is the
telos what is the purpose um
for the ultimate dreamer infinite
consciousness
to make the dream it
what is the purpose of it and in terms
of trajectory
to heading towards some sort of a god
head
what what happens do we oroboros
another dream is that yeah and
and what's the relationship with
artificial intelligence and
uh like virtual realities re and
simulation theory
with that godhead and that continued
auroboros please rupert
but my my mother who first
introduced me to these matters in my in
my mid teens
uh reminds me quite often that when i
was
about seven years old i
said to her i think that the entire
universe is god's dream and that
our part in the dream is to make
god's dream as nicer dream as possible
well that was an innocent naive
seven-year-old's way
of expressing what we are speaking of
now and i have to confess that
i have not evolved very much over the
intervening
50 or so years i still basically feel
the same thing although i express it in
somewhat more sophisticated language but
so i still think
that the universe is god's dream i don't
often use that language although i
am really a closet sufi i tend not to
use that
language because the word god has
is so intolerable to so many people for
for obvious reasons it has been abused
so much so i tend not to use that
language i i consider this to be the
activity of an
infinite consciousness as to the purpose
of it
to answer your question i would no
longer say that i think its purpose is
to
be as nice as possible a dream for god
to have so that god doesn't have to have
nightmares or
it's uh it's ultimate purpose i i would
suggest
is is that the the
is for the reality to
shine unobscured through the illusion
so the the illusion being the appearance
of multiplicity and diversity
which for most of us
conceals its reality
i would suggest that the purpose if we
can speak of purpose
is for that the illusion the appearance
of multiplicity
and diversity not to conceal its reality
but to
reveal its reality to express it to
communicate it to share it
to celebrate it in other words
for for the appearance to become
increasingly transparent
to its reality yes
yes and i believe uh
beautiful and i believe uh francis uh
lucille says
uh it's a eternal uh fourth of july
fireworks
yes yeah he said that much i think yes
yes
yes and uh i i i like
i like that as uh as as the purpose
um for for the reality to shine through
the
um illusion um yeah i
like i like that and and it does seem
like
it's there's like a there's a titration
in a sense if we can use that uh more
and more towards that
towards that remembrance and um
and it it and that's rupert
there's a lot about artificial
intelligence and virtual realities and
simulations that i think have a lot to
do with the godhead
that's for another conversation let's
not get started on that now
okay